slippery slopes are all around us and
we've been slipping on so many and at
this point where I think surrogacy
especially commercial surrogacy and
cross-border Commercial surrogacy it
just feels like
you know one of those slopes that you
know it's you can tell when you reach
the precipice that it's like this this
is the direction it's going into and
we're just about there and we're taking
the first step down the slope and it's
you know the The Darkness at the bottom
is essentially you know people ordering
babies for anything one of the
interesting things that has risen with
this whole uh natalism conversation is a
rise of surrogacy now you look at it on
the surface you go okay this is you know
this is good you know people who can't
have kids can have kids what's what's
wrong with that and then you look into
it you go oh this is dark yeah yeah it's
a strange thing because obviously the
kind of the more kind of napkin
presentation of the case for surrogacy
is is really nice you know you have you
know women who maybe don't are not of
you know great means you know but are
willing to do it for kind of generously
to to help someone who maybe is
infertile and they really want their own
child and this is the only way they can
have it it's really you know it kind of
pulls on the heartstrings especially if
you're someone who knows you know our
infertile yourself or you know it's it's
it's it's tough out there like I said
you know a lot of people are having
trouble with this
um and it feels like oh you know you you
scratch my back I scratch yours type of
situation but I think the the case for
it
um or against it in a way is kind of a
case of like like virtual ethics like if
we allow this type of um activity to to
start and if we allow this little Edge
case where you know it's obviously
virtuous and nice
um the thing is not going to stay there
you know we have we have you know
slippery slopes are all around us and
we've been slipping on so many uh and at
this point where I think surrogacy
especially commercial surrogacy and
cross-border Commercial surrogacy
is already a little bit of a of a
strange
um beast because you know especially now
with the war in Ukraine you know this is
kind of a lot of the cup uncovered was
essentially that a lot of people who are
evacuating were these kind of like big
brother style houses of women who you
know were living kind of in a cluster at
home I don't know pregnant with some
westerners baby and they were kind of
keep being kept in sort of um
I don't know observation so that the the
moms and dads or whoever was ordering
the baby from abroad was uh yeah it was
kept in check of how the ladies were
doing and stuff like that so I don't
know it was a
yeah I mean you could see this we're
still at the beginning of this and this
is already kind of you know it feels a
little bit predatory and it feels a bit
predatory to interrupt and just
completely like commercially sever the
bond between Mom and baby I mean I've
I've had a baby I'm gonna have one again
very soon and it's uh the idea that you
know in the hospital even though if I
signed the contract before obviously you
know because I consented to this
previously without knowing how I'd feel
when the baby arrived
um I would just have to you know give
the baby you know just hand it over and
say sayonara I'm gonna go home now
um so yeah there's also a lot of you
know physical costs involved
um yeah it's it's you know recovering
from pregnancy is not always easy
there's risks of you know risks that are
really hard to calculate in advance as
well in terms of the impact on your
health you know some women you know end
up having like stress fractures uterine
ruptures all sorts of you know things
that just happened in the course of not
being pregnant might lead to infertility
for themselves afterwards so yeah I mean
obviously if someone's more of a
Libertarian event they say okay you know
you put this in a disclaimer put it in
the contract obviously let them know
that this you know side effects might
include this this and this but um I
think when it comes to something so
profound as the the bond between a child
and and mother
um you know I don't think your body
knows that oh this is someone else's egg
and this is some you know third-party
sperm and you know this is a strange
it's a different situation but yeah it
just feels like
you know one of those slopes that you
know it's you can tell when you reach
the precipice that it's like this this
is the direction it's going into and
we're just about there and we're taking
the first step down the slope and it's
you know the The Darkness at the bottom
is essentially you know people ordering
babies for anything yeah well it comes
back to the point you were making about
the markets like what is the commodity
that's being traded in that exchange
and it starts to get a little bit uh
creepy very quickly and then first
Francis says once you look into it then
it sort of starts to make sense a little
bit
thank you
foreign